después de 80 días en el mar y 12 largos
años de espera y anime está bien ha
regresado de manera gloriosa ha
conseguido la victoria en la donde globe
la regata de vela más dura del mundo
[Aplausos]
siento que estoy soñando no parece real
es extraño pasar de estar totalmente
aislado a esto la fiesta los fuegos
artificiales la gente que ha salido a
pesar de las difíciles circunstancias
todavía no me creo lo que ha pasado sigo
pensando en la carrera aunque ya termino
este era mis sueños desde la infancia
la contrarreloj en solitario sin escalas
por el océano atlántico que pasa más
allá de los tres cabos y regresa
cruzando el atlántico otra vez tuvo su
final más cercano con cinco capitanes
todavía en la carrera en el último día
al final fue el bonus de tiempo debe
estar en lo que marcó la diferencia se
le otorgó por cambiar de rumbo para
participar en el dramático rescate de
kevin escoffier después de que su bote
se partiera en 2
el primer intento debe estar en 2008 no
podía haber sido peor después de apenas
30 horas en el mar perdió su mástil y
tuvo que rendirse pero mantuvo vivo el
sueño y continuó participando en
carreras costeras y transatlánticas
ganando algunas de ellas emprendedor e
ingeniero de formación de estaban dejó
su huella en la one the globe incluso
antes de esa victoria soñada el
generador hidroeléctrico que desarrolló
se ha convertido en estándar en todos
los barcos de la competición